first of all thanks so much for having
me I just wanted to introduce myself my
name is Sanjay
um I work at a company called the casa
where I'm the director of engineering
and I've been here basically since the
company started up about four years ago
I'm a career Healthcare technology
person so
um I I love working on software to to
try to make Healthcare in this country
at least just a little bit better and
that's what I've spent my entire career
on
um and I live in San Francisco and I I
really apologize that due to getting ill
last second I wasn't able to travel in
person for the conference
um but uh I hope hope you enjoy the talk
and
um if if you do have questions along the
way
um I can't see each of you very well but
if you have a way to flag me down feel
free otherwise I'm happy to stay on
afterwards and and
talk and take questions as well
um okay just uh just to motivate
um basically what this company does uh
very very briefly healthcare
administration in the United States is
incredibly expensive
um and and that cost gets passed down to
the patient so there's a stat here that
says that the number one cause of
personal bankruptcy in the United States
is due to unexpected medical bills which
is really sad and it's something we're
trying to fix and additionally over 25
percent of annual Health Care spending
which is over 250 billion dollars a year
is considered wasteful administrative
work and our goal at a casa is basically
to automate all of this and to to take
some of the paperwork out of Health Care
and make it so that computers can do the
boring stuff and humans who work at
hospitals can actually focus on patient
care that's that's what we're trying to
achieve
oops
um
okay
now switching more into a technical gear
what does the casa actually do so we use
machine learning to automate tasks that
cannot be done via apis and we build a
platform that's generic to any industry
but but right now we focus on health
care because there's just an enormous
amount of manual repetitive human work
that's being done in healthcare every
day and you know one of our core value
propositions is and I'll talk about this
a little bit more is basically that we
can build an API
for any manual task by using the
graphical user interface of the Software
System that's being used so with that if
you've heard of robotic process
automation what this means is if we're
dealing with software systems that
people are doing manual work in and and
don't have good API support we can build
computer programs that you call it as if
it's an API but actually our program is
spinning up a virtual machine actually
logging into the GUI of the software
system and using computer vision and
controlling the keyboard and mouse to to
be able to navigate around the screen do
data entry scrape data from the screen
do web scraping and so on and so that's
that's kind of the idea is that
um we can we can do automations and a
lot of these systems that that
previously were only open to manual work
and so some examples of that in
healthcare are every hospital uses a
desktop app called an electronic health
record system
these are typically uh decades-old
applications that have very very limited
API support and so the vast majority of
work is done over the GUI and so every
hospital employs like an army of humans
to be doing all of this manual work and
that's something that we can automate
and similarly health insurance companies
have websites that you can use to answer
questions like what's the status of my
claim or to submit an appeal or do
things like that but they also don't
have very good API support and so we can
build web scrapers to to automate some
of those common common flows
um I'm not going to pause a lot for
questions just because I can't see you
all but uh if if you do have any
questions again just just flag me down
and interrupt me
um okay getting a little bit more
detailed
um our automations include basically two
types of of automation what I call
workflow Automation and information
extraction so the first is workflow
Automation and what that means is we are
mimicking you know a sequence of of
clicks and data scrapes and data entry
that a human would normally have to do
so for example navigate to a claim in
the electronic health record system
scrape all that claim info from the
system and then oops and then go open up
a web browser and type that info into
the health insurance company website and
click where's my claim
read the website response and understand
what it says and then based on what it
says go back to your desktop application
and update the state of the claim in the
in the electronic health record system
so basically we're like you know trying
to sync the state of this data between
two parties that aren't communicating
very well and we also have I would say
some more traditional machine learning
tasks
um like information extraction tasks so
for example you go to the doctor's
office and they ask for your insurance
card and they scan it into the system
that gives them the jpeg or a PNG so you
know something that's not not structured
data and we can run our OCR algorithms
for example to to pull out all the
structured data from insurance cards or
from health insurance company web pages
and so on
um and really all I wanted to show on
this slide we don't have to get into the
details is that uh some of these
Hospital workflows can be really Dynamic
and complex actually what I'm showing
here is a simple one just because it
fits on the slide but we often build
workflows for hospitals that have you
know hundreds of branching points they
have looping you need conditional logic
sometimes you don't know which path you
have to take until you get halfway
through the search graph and see the
intermediate results and so this is
starting to motivate why we were
thinking about a workflow engine is that
we need to express these arbitrarily
complex workflows and they're not easily
expressed as like a dag up front that
you can just go and execute and
sometimes the search graph is much more
complicated than that
so digging a little deeper into what
Acasa does because this this may help
motivate the workflow engine even more
um
we've fundamentally believe that human
support is critical for automation
challenges so automation is always going
to hit edge cases you see this in the
self-driving car world as well which is
what I'm showing on the right side and
we we believe that robots work best when
they can seamlessly collaborate with
humans and that was a core principle
when we built our platform was this idea
of of human in the loop Automation and
what that means is that at any time if a
bot has low confidence it can call for
help and instantly be taken over by a
human on our Ops Team
now we aren't driving cars we are you
know doing automation for healthcare and
what that means is sometimes this human
takeover can be a little bit higher
latency
and that that ends up being something
that that kind of motivates look that
I'll talk about further that motivates
some Concepts in our workflow engine
the other idea is
um
is this idea of customization
um by using standard building blocks so
we have a bunch of Standard Building
Blocks or API calls for example to
scrape websites or scrape information
off of a screen enter data into a
hospital electronic health record system
and so on you can think of these as you
know API calls in our library that we
can leverage but every single Hospital
wants a customized workflow
um you know there's a saying in
healthcare that if if you've seen one
Hospital you've seen one Hospital like
nothing nothing generalizes and
um and so we need to provide
customization by stitching together all
of these building blocks in different
and unique ways for every customer and
what that means is that in the limit
Acasa might have to write thousands of
workflows because again every Co every
hospital is unique and
as such we wanted to optimize for making
the workflows extremely easy to write so
we wanted to give people like a single
python script that actually feels like
python should be able to do conditionals
and looping and you know and higher
order logic
um and we didn't want to make people
write yaml or something like that
because we're going to be writing these
workflows over and over and over again
and just wanted to make it as quick as
possible so that was a motivating factor
and then the
final motivating factor here is that
sometimes our API calls have a lot of
latency involved so most of our API
calls wrap operations that are happening
in external systems like electronic
health record system and some of these
operations can take minutes to execute
or let's say we call for help from a
human and it's outside of business hours
so we our Ops team is not readily
available sometimes it can take
um you know 30 minutes or an hour to get
someone online to go help the bot and
it's uh it's inefficient for the client
process to to just block while waiting
for these calls to return because it
could go do something else that's useful
during that time and so we needed our
we needed our calls to be async but we
didn't want to make the workflows really
complicated to write and have people
thinking about async logic
um the other thing that's important for
us is that if an automation fails part
way through the workflow we actually
don't want to just restart it from the
beginning
restarting is not only inefficient but
it's also dangerous because we are
mutating data in external systems that
we don't control so for example if
there's a 10-step workflow and we fail
at step five it's not actually safe to
redo steps one through four because
maybe we submitted an appeal on behalf
of the hospital or or
um you know did something like that
um
so the question here is how do we get
async execution
retries and resuming while still
preserving the expressive syntax of
python and making our workflows
extremely easy to write
um okay and that takes me into
sort of the first first technical
chapter of this talk which is going to
be talking about item potent apis
I apologize I actually need
one second because it looks like uh
looks like my
Company software update is trying to
update Microsoft teams right now which
is a very poorly timed
um
if I drop off this call and hop back on
right now will that mess things up
we don't really know but we can chat
okay let's give it a try I'm sorry about
that it looks like I can't override this
I'll be back in
30 seconds
that was good okay
thank you
well also as a separate announcement if
you're getting lunch you can come back
and eat it in here
um so yeah
apparently they don't like people just
being on the hallways and the hallways
just eating on the floor
okay
that's very good
all right are we back yeah okay there's
two of you but
um oh there's two of me
yeah the other one bro let's see
um
all right we're good we're good to go
okay okay great
sorry sorry about that okay here we go
so
um I wanted to introduce this concept of
item potency which many of you may be
familiar with an item potent operation
is one that can be applied multiple
times without changing the results
beyond the initial application right so
in math for example multiplying by zero
is item potent so no matter how many
times you do it you're gonna you're
gonna get the same result after the
first application
um whereas if you look at HTTP
um get requests put requests and and
delete are all item potent but notably
post is not right so if you submit the
same post request twice you're actually
going to create two resources
um and as I mentioned our automations
can mutate state in external systems
such as ehrs and our workflows can fail
Midway due to issues outside of our
control like maybe the customer VPN goes
down and when the workflow retries we
don't want to repeat mutations that
we've already done so we need item
potent apis to give us what's called
Atmos once semantics which is basically
a guarantee that we will only do the
work at most one time you know we're not
going to duplicate the work if we only
intended to do it once
and um AWS published this really
excellent blog post
um called making retry safe with item
potent apis I recommend you read it I'll
try to give you a very brief summary of
it and and they talk about having the
same problem internally
so the blog post talks about the example
they use is creating an ec2 instance so
to the client you know creating an ec2
instance seems simple but internally at
AWS it actually requires several API
calls Each of which has some chance of
failure associated with it for example
they have to pull together a network
interface an EBA EBS volume a VM and
each of these API calls internally can
fail and their question is how do we
make sure that we end up with exactly
one ec2 instance at the end
and you know specifically let's say the
client submits the request and the
request times out so client doesn't know
what happened so they're just going to
submit it again but they probably don't
want a second ec2 instance you know they
probably want
um
you know they're probably just following
up on their initial request and trying
to figure out what happened and so aws's
question is
um how does AWS figure out if a you know
a retry that's coming in is actually is
actually a retry of a previous request
or or if it's a unique request now
so the first idea they have is that on
the server side they can hash all the
parameters that are coming into the
function call
then dedupe requests that way so for
example if they see a function call that
has all the same parameters
um as a very recent function call within
some time window then then they decide
that it's a duplicate and they they
coalesce it and only do the work once
and give you back one ec2 instance but
this is kind of weird because sometimes
you may actually want to identical ec2
instances around the same time and
that's a totally valid option
um and the other option that they talk
about is that the client uh basically
generates a unique token and adds that
to its request and the client can retry
as many times as it wants but it's
always passing in this token that
doesn't change and so
if it's a retry the client passes in the
same token but but then if the client
says actually I want a second dc2
instance it makes a new token and
submits a request again so basically the
client is controlling the semantics here
and this is what AWS actually uses I
think this is a very powerful concept
you may be wondering you know you've
never had to generate a token when
making an ec2 instance and that's
because the the SDK handles all of this
for you but this concept is really
powerful because it allows the client to
distinguish between basically what's a
retry of a previous request
and you know what is a new request that
you want new work to be done for
and item potent apis are interesting
because they they lead to this idea of
replayable workflows so to Casa all of
our internal apis follow the client
token pattern which means if the client
resubmits the same request with the same
client token within you know a
reasonable window of time the response
is immediately returned from the
server's cache like the server doesn't
even try to do the work again this is at
most one semantics you know we're only
going to do the work once
um and so then if you imagine this case
I've been talking about a workflow fails
Midway through a series of API calls
um what we can do now is we can simply
restart it from the very beginning and
just fire off all of the API calls again
starting from the first one and if the
call had already been made then the
server is going to recognize that hey
I've seen this client token before and
it's just going to instantly return the
response from the cache and then once
you get to the part that failed where
you never got to submit the you know the
sixth API call in the workflow the
server doesn't see any cached result and
so it starts doing the work and this
pattern creates what we call replayable
workflows that allow you to basically
replay everything from the beginning and
you don't have to worry about saving
intermediate state or or remembering
where you left off which makes the code
very simple to write
okay so quick time check okay I will um
now try to summarize how we built a
workflow engine on top of the idea of
replayable workflows and I'm going to go
a little bit fast uh just just for time
but happy to stay afterwards for
questions
okay the first thing that's important to
understand I'm going to walk you through
basically Slide by slide what the
architecture looks like so an engineer
writes these these functions or these
building blocks that I talked about to
do things like scraping EHR or perform
data entry or run an ml algorithm or so
on and they they decorate each function
with our workflow.task decorator and
there's a single python script where
they sort of tie together all the
functions you know calling them in the
right order taking the output of of one
API call and passing it as the input to
the next one and so on and this this
script looks super simple and you write
the script as if it's executing in a
completely synchronous manner but what
this decorator is doing is that as the
script executes rather than
uh invoking the functions directly The
Decorator is actually pushing the
functions onto a queue
and then it immediately raises a pending
exception to say that hey this function
is still pending so
um you know you can exit now and come
back and check it later
so the takeaway here is the engineer
writes a single python script that looks
super simple it looks like it's
synchronous you can do for Loops you can
do conditionals you can do whatever you
want
but instead of actually
running these building blocks these API
calls directly we're pushing them onto a
queue
um or they will be run asynchronously
and we don't we don't block while
waiting for these things to run because
again sometimes they can take several
minutes so so we exit and the process
can do something else
now on the other side of the queue we
have the workers so we have a pool of
workers that's running and the worker is
you're dequeuing tasks from the queue
and then actually executing the function
and when the worker finishes executing
the function it's going to write its
results to the database by the way and
and mark the tasks is done so
um in healthcare we typically don't have
massive data and additionally due to
data privacy regulations we have to
Shard all our databases by customer
anyways and that means that right now
using the the database basically
postgres is a results store has worked
perfectly fine for our workflow engine
though if we ever scale to much bigger
data sets that we would probably Swap
this out but right now we use basically
a postgres based queue and so so where
you using postgres both as the queue and
as the results store
and we used an open source library and
did a couple cool things on top of it
like adding this results table to store
status and results of each task so you
don't get this fire and forget model
where you know you you submitted a task
to the queue but you have no idea what
happened to it we also added a rest API
on top of the queuing library so that
you can enqueue tasks from non-python
code you can enqueue it from A bash
script or whatever
um but the main Takeaway on this slide
is uh workers are pulling tasks off of
the queue and and executing them
according to
um you know task level priorities that
we're setting
um so then okay so what we've talked
about so far is you write a script as
the script executes it doesn't actually
do the work but it pushes the work onto
a queue then you have workers that are
grabbing the work off of that queue and
doing the work and writing the results
to a database so then at some point the
original script needs to get the results
and kind of keep pushing the workflow
forward as the results are being done
so as I said the workflow gets um you
know the special exception class we
created called the pending exception
immediately when it first submits a
function call and then the workflow
retries periodically to see if the work
is done
but what's important is that there's no
status endpoint here so the workflow is
not remembering
um what you know what call it submitted
last and and calling the status endpoint
for that API instead it's it's doing
this replay idea that I told you about
where the workflow just restarts from
the very beginning oops and fires off
the same chain of requests with the same
client tokens and so again the worker
checks the cash
okay uh the worker checks the cash and
if it's already seen a client token it
doesn't do the work again and it it just
Returns the results from the cache or if
the results are still pending then it
raises pending exception again to tell
you that the task is still in progress
so this is how this idea of of Replay
becomes real which is that the workflow
keeps retrying it starts from the
beginning let's say let's say previously
it had gotten through five out of 10 API
calls these first five are going to be
instant on the replay because you you
basically you submit the function call
immediately get the cash result back
submit the next function call
immediately get the cash result back and
so on and if we wanted even lower
latency then then this idea of polling
we also implemented notification which
means that when a when a worker
completes the task it knows who's
waiting on it and it it can basically
call a call back to go notify that
dependent task
so the Takeaway on this slide is that
the workflow can just retry the exact
same code
um it doesn't have any special code for
statusing or or anything like that and
work doesn't get duplicated based on the
client token semantics
um okay so I told you we're pushing work
onto a queue right so we need a
consistent way to serialize and
deserialize task inputs and outputs
um and so the way we do that is that all
function inputs and all return values
are pedantic models and when we are
pushing work onto the queue the
arguments get serialized and we write
them into the database
um and then when the worker is picking
up work off of the queue it's it's
deserializing the arguments from the
database so now it has the arguments
that it needs to run the function with
and then when it finishes it takes the
return value and serializes those and
writes it back to the database and so
basically all I'm saying here is that we
need a consistent way to pass inputs and
outputs around and make sure we don't
lose anything in Translation because we
have this this intermediate layer of the
queue we just need to make sure that we
are serializing and deserializing
everything correctly
and that's what we're using pedantic for
um and then the last part which
obviously is pretty important because
it's kind of how all the magic works is
about how we generate client tokens okay
it looks like still have a few minutes
um okay
so the framework
I'll say a statement and then I'll try
to explain what that means
the workflow engine framework
automatically generates client tokens in
a way that takes into account what we
call the the call stack provenance so
what I mean when I say call stack
provenance is it takes into account you
know everything that's happened up above
it in the call stack and if if something
there has changed you know like if if
some parent node or ancestor node
changed then we automatically invalidate
all the sentence and recompute them
but if everything in the ancestry is is
the same
um here actually then let's let's talk
about this okay so
you can imagine
a python script being represented as
basically a call graph where you have
like some some root node like a main
method
um and then any other node has a parent
right because you have functions that
are calling other functions
for the root node we calculate the
client token by generating a hash of the
arguments to the to the to the main
method or whatever the method is that
initializes the program
um
but then any other function call like
let's say function X is always going to
be invoked by some some parent function
y
okay and so how we generate the client
token for function X is the client token
is the hash of all the arguments to X
but it also hashes it also includes in
the hash function the client token of
its parent function y and so this gets
us the desired behavior
um I'm going to try to go slow here or
repeat this because this is important so
if the arguments to the child task in
this case that child task is is function
X the arguments to function X Change and
we get a new client token because what
we're hashing is going to change like we
have a different argument in here we get
a new client token and we do the work
again and that's usually what we want
because we don't want to be returning a
result from a cache if we're now passing
in different arguments so so that's
totally reasonable to redo the work if
we change the arguments to the function
but additionally
if any arguments change anywhere up in
the call stack like in the ancestry then
what's going to happen you know by the
same logic is that that parent function
is going to get a new client token and
since the parent function client token
is included when you're creating the
child client token you basically
invalidate all of The Descendants and
recompute
um and so I know this is a little
complicated happy to take questions
about it later
um but the the key ideas here are that
we can replay everything and as long as
you know no arguments change
um we we get replay behavior for free we
instantly get results back from the cash
um but if any arguments change and you
want to invalidate results that behavior
also comes for free and our framework
includes a decorator that automatically
generates client tokens in this manner
so that the engineer doesn't have to
think about it
okay
I think this is my last slide or one of
my last slides so putting it all
together just starting to sum up the
experience here
an engineer is writing a python script
the code looks super simple and it looks
like it's synchronous code but during
execution tasks are actually pushed onto
a queue rather than executed you know in
process
on the other end of the queue you have
workers that are pulling the queue and
working tasks in order of priority
and the workflow script is continuously
retrying and as it gets results back
it's firing off the next API call
basically queuing up the next task
and no duplicate work is done since
client tokens are generated in a
deterministic manner and the workflow
code looks really simple
and
you know if we are waiting on a high
latency task like let's say we are now
asking a human to go label some data and
it's in the middle of the night so we
may not get a human to help us for a
couple hours we're not blocking uh and
waiting for a human during that time you
know we submitted an API call but we get
the control of the process back and the
workers are free to go pick up other
tasks during that time that that can be
worked in parallel for example scraping
more websites or scraping more data from
the EHR
eventually when we when you know when
the human wakes up in the morning and
gets to this task then we'll no longer
get a pending exception the next time we
go to poll it and we can we can kind of
move that workflow forward but while
we're while we're waiting for them we
our workers can go do other things and
aren't being consumed with that
um okay so I think that's all I got I
had some some screenshots here just to
show that we also built a nice front end
on top of it
um and that allows you to kind of see
how everything is working and allows you
to debug and see all the all the inputs
and outputs
um the stack trays if if a function has
an error and so on
um
let's see
probably don't have time for much of it
or running a little bit late um okay
let's thank our speaker
there are any are there any questions
do we have a few questions also it's
we're at 12 30 so if you want to head
out feel free we're not we're not
stopping you but uh let's we can also
stick around for Q a
yeah um I was wondering if you looked at
existing orchestrators that are out
there and what uh you found deficient or
LED you to build your own yeah for sure
uh we looked at a bunch actually I um I
have another talk that I sometimes give
on the sort of the the audit that we did
um there were a few categories a lot of
a lot of worklo engines out there were
um built around this idea of
you know you
you write a dag and then they go they go
execute that dag very efficiently for
you
um and that didn't work for us because a
lot of our workflows that I mentioned
are super Dynamic and are actually just
difficult to express those dags that was
one area
um there were other tools
um
like uh
um Cadence and temporal and prefect that
looked pretty interesting to us
and I think maybe timing was a little
bit wrong so we're a python shop and I
think the temporal python support was
was not great at least at the time when
we were needing a solution
prefect if you haven't looked at it
looks looks quite interesting and and
for a prefect V2 looks fairly similar to
what we ended up building but it didn't
exist when we built this
um so yeah that's that's kind of the
short summary but happy to go into a lot
more detail
a great dog
um I had a question about how do you
actually maintain the order of
operations uh if you actually have a tag
so you're doing like asynchronous work
and then you have this workflow like
task a or function a b c they need to go
in order right and they're queued up and
uh you're actually doing task ABC
asynchronously of each other or is Task
B RC waiting for B and then B waiting
for the output of it yeah yeah good
question yeah so uh certainly when you
have sequential tasks like that so
you'll you'll queue up a first you'll
get a pending exception work 12 will
stop right there you haven't even queued
up B yet
um once you get the results of a back
um this is assuming I mean
um assuming you want this linear flow
where uh B requires a is output and C
requires B's output and so on yeah um so
you you only queue them up one at a time
um and uh once you go to poll and you
don't get a pending exception then uh
then you cue the next one up so that's
uh basically supported by default if you
want that sort of linear execution we
also do support Syntax for in parallel
creating you know
uh
a bunch of tasks at once if you do want
them to run in parallel
got it and thank you and all of this uh
or any other tools open source I didn't
catch that can we yeah no not right now
but that's something we're hoping to do
either
uh probably early next year is Our Hope
um we would really love to make this
open source great thank you
all right thanks a lot
um Andre sorry for the technical
difficulties
um one more question okay
hi great talk thank you so much I just
wanted to know how this indicates with
uh emr's like Epic
writers and who are your most important
customers
okay
yeah absolutely
um we uh we work with uh some of the
biggest Health Systems in the world
though I don't think I'm at the Liberty
to disclose all of their names
um you can look on our website acasa.com
for the ones that that are publicly
disclosed but um yeah some of some of
the biggest Hospital Systems in the
world are our customers we integrate
with all the different emrs epic Cerner
and so on
um and basically how this works is you
know what I talked about is we can we
can build a robot
to basically act like a human and and
control the desktop and then from there
we can program the robot
to do different things based on what the
equivalent human person would be doing
so maybe in one case it is
um you know submitting appeals uh based
on denials that were incorrect in
another case it might be checking the
status of claims and flagging them in
the system if if they need to be worked
on so
um so basically that's that's kind of
our whole business is uh offering like a
virtual full-time employee
um and and just making it so that a
robot it can be can do all the same
stuff as a human but uh obviously way
faster and way more productive
foreign
thanks for the talk I just really
appreciate everything you've talked
about today
um my question is about so in the
seminar description you mentioned uh
fast API and I was just wondering if
that was
like if you guys actually use that as as
part of your toolkit and and if so how
did you come to that decision yeah we do
and sorry I I totally forgot to cover
that
um one thing that's super cool is uh
basically any uh anything you tag as a
as a workflow task using our decorator
automatically gets exposed as a fast API
endpoint so that's another part of what
our decorator does and so that means
that you can queue up these tasks again
like from A bash script or from another
programming language just by hitting the
fast API endpoint and so so that's what
we're we're using fast API for is
basically as uh as a rest API on top of
the queue and making it so that
um you know if you are another service
within the company you don't have to
know that we use queuing or any of that
like you know that's the intern General
detail that you shouldn't care about you
just submit an API request to call that
the endpoint that you want and then
what what we're going to do on our end
is push that function onto a queue and
have a worker go work on it does that
make sense
cool awesome well thanks again and it's
lunchtime
right
thanks Sanjay alrighty thanks so much I
apologize for the technical difficulties
oh no it's our fault
okay bye